[Music]
this news just came in in the middle of
us filming
but
after 70 years on the throne
queen elizabeth has passed away at the
age of 96.
70 years 70 is she the longest serving
monarch yeah 70 man that's classy
classy yeah classy so she she she
started in her twenties then huh
yeah she just like shook down that would
be 96-70
wow
that's the kind of commentary that we
get on this show
we do the math for you that's right
we're very political here we get it yeah
he's like we understand there's a knife
through the lung i think he might be
dead
didn't she like just so the the new
prime minister just got sworn in right
and then the queen was involved in that
i saw a picture of that wow you know a
lot about this i'm actually pretty
ignorant with royal family stuff me too
yeah we all should be though right i
don't know how the system works and it
does nothing for me it's it's ceremony
mostly right so the queen like is there
as a ceremonial like passing of the
torch she's part of like that process
like just
just to do it like for photos and stuff
and it's important i guess for the
culture over there i don't really know
it's tourism does something crazy happen
now that prince charles is the king of
england oh so he's the new dog i think
he gets his face i'm not kidding on all
the new bank notes what so they're going
to take out all the elizabeth well no
they don't take them out but i think the
new ones will have prince charles's face
on them that's weird oh and then they'll
take the old ones out of circulation
over time i don't know about that is
that the only thing that comes with
being king i think they get tonight it's
a branding they did lose hella power
they lost helipower i think they do a
lot of like
events yeah what about like if you're
going to be a sir dj
that'll be so sick
don't date the sword yeah they do the
night that's you're right yeah they
knight people well when's the last time
someone got knighted oh it happens all
the time yeah they do like movie stars
didn't like bear girls get knighted or
something i think jessica alba got an
added dude
kristen crook did dave christopher
dame jessica alba yeah i wouldn't be
surprised did you know that there's
people that refuse being knighted i
didn't think that was even a thing and
that metal as hell that's pretty tight
though i want to get knighted
who refused it people that don't want
the
responsibility and all that
things that come with it what comes with
it no they're anti-monarchy so they're
like oh
they don't okay like the imperialist
stuff but what about prince andrew the
most famous
royal the greatest royal he's the
greatest i'm like sweaty andrew what
makes him the greatest why is he your
favorite you know just because his you
know ties with epstein
you're a fan of that
but what happens to him like does he
does he not get a shot at the throne i
don't think he's next in line yeah it
goes in order yeah is he anywhere in the
top five he would have to do like a like
a 16 team parlay
and just
just really run the table you'd have to
you'd have to run the [ __ ] table you
know
so yeah
does that mean so when you said they
have limited power now
what what do they have power to do like
what would king charles be able could he
just make these outrageous laws out of
nowhere
no they don't it's all ceremonial yeah
they don't have anything like that wow
dude what is scam the wrong
taxpayer money to preserve this
historical
living piece so it's like funding a road
at least believe it or not museum
basically got it hey dude but they have
their own royal guard or whatever that
protects their own home their own house
so that's kind of that guy have any
martial arts training at all hell no no
they're just standing there dude they
got cool hats so let's say parliament
reaches a standstill can they come and
influence or even talk like when it's
out of session and slowly coax things
into oh you know what they can do is um
they can give their blessing on the
prime minister and [ __ ] like that
because recently
liz told boris to resign
she nudged them to resign so they kind
of have lobbying power then huh
they definitely have influence in some
sense yeah influence yeah i mean the way
that like kim kardashian has influence
on trump right i think honestly i think
there is
you can't really divorce politics from
brandon marketing a celebrity it's like
all
one thing now but that's pre-diarrhea
yeah i don't think she has that kind of
influence now right that was kind of
like her samson hair was like she has
diarrhea diarrhea she is yeah but she
passed the bar i heard
yeah she yeah she did yeah she didn't
pass no one took the test for her well i
seem like she's isn't there like two
different bars you have to take like the
pre-bar and then the bar
as far as i went to law school and in my
time there was just one bar
there's a bar you take for california
for every state right and so maybe
that's like if you want to practice in
new york after this like you have to
take it again for the new york law what
would be the easiest state west virginia
oh there are easy states um yeah i think
once you and really what that means is
that there's so many lawyers in these
particular regions so yeah i'm sure if
you go to like montana it's probably
pretty easy to pass the bar so if i if
like you were in trouble and i was like
don't worry i'm a lawyer got my degree
in north dakota yeah you're going to be
like oh [ __ ]
well like that
i think you'd be just as versed in like
federal law but yeah maybe more of the
local law i don't know what type of law
was it that you got into anywhere that
you wanted when you go into what i
wanted to get into
i went to school because i was like
heavily involved in activism at the time
like in when i was in high school and so
i thought i was going in for more like
public interest humanitarian uh oriented
work and by the end of it i was looking
more like intellectual property like
trademark because i started my brand and
then i was curious about that side of
things you found where the money was
brothers
on dude it's actually very you're
talking to a real real every lawyer who
goes in with good intentions at some
point in the middle is just like they're
saddled with that and then they're like
i can't make a living being this kind of
a lawyer i need to work for a firm how
do i beat larry h parker like he's about
to die soon right but i think i want to
take the next monarch yeah because the
new guy is the accidente guy the spanish
guy
and larry's been doing commercials with
his son now yeah
there's two of them doing in the
commercial accident this guy no no no
you know
he's like the mexican larry yeah yeah it
has like a squad now yeah there's i've
seen there's like multiple it's like a
justice league of larry parker and you
know he's have you seen these cats in
vegas though like i was watching the
super bowl and there's this guy who's
like he's a lawyer but he [ __ ] loves
himself right
so you guys probably saw this [ __ ] i
know bart's probably seen this [ __ ] but
like this is a lawyer like wears armani
suits and he gets out of like really
expensive cars that he rented for this
for the commercial and he and like all
of his like [ __ ] billboards around
town are basically like we win but it's
like you could you can oh yeah i've seen
that guy no this guy it just makes you
realize like man i'll be spending a lot
of money for this guy to like make
himself look tight around town like
that's what that's what i think about
when i see his advertisements i don't
think he's funding his image yeah you're
finding his image it doesn't
seem like he's going to do a good job
for me at all right well it's all
marketing he's gonna spend it on gucci
shoes california has what sweet james
have you ever seen that guy sweet james
yeah
he sounds like he's like the the modern
larry h park guys like he's just like a
cool like better call saul looking yeah
he's a suave guy but his name is sweet
james sweet sweet or jacob and ronnie oh
yeah oh the persians there's a lot of
good persons jacob armani is a big one
he's always at the laker games has boxes
and stuff like he has jingles on power
106 and yeah wow do you guys think
prince charles right now is kind of like
you know he's been waiting for this
moment like finally we're gonna get to
see some [ __ ] but that was old too how
old is he he's like 70. what does he
look like
and why does it sound so much more
threatening when it's king prince yeah
when it's like queen elizabeth you're
like oh it's endearing you know it's
like oh for the queen but now it's like
oh it's for the king it seems i don't
know i mean
there's so many movies and tv shows
about the queen and the like the queen
always
almost seems like the bigger villain
like the villainous you know disney
movies it's always just like the evil
the evil queen yeah yeah yeah right
that's charles barkley oh my god
that is
[Laughter]
you know queen victoria
she it was a movie about queen victoria
in an indian servant and they had a
little bit of a like thing going on once
again joe probably half watched this
movie was doing something
yeah he's like yeah they were like
hanging out and then you turned it off
for spaceship hawaiian [ __ ] airlines
i landed early i see
daddy looks [ __ ] up yeah
not prince the f or phil he killed diana
remember yeah that's right yeah phillip
died recently right yeah a couple months
ago yeah do you think this has anything
to do with the passing of the queen no
because he could have been king but she
never [ __ ] let him be it she was like
oh man i loved him so much he passes now
i'm gone
she could have made him king yeah you
know she was 96.
he's always been a prince she never gave
her power
here's a question how long do you think
she's been dead for
oh
that's the real question
what's your guess i think it's probably
been at least a few days
really
they're not gonna announce it at the
same time that it happens right they
need to get a lot of things in order do
you think they can keep secrets though
what if it leaked i think so i don't
know well all the families started
moving in today like they started making
the pilgrimage and so i think this has
been in the you can't just do this
because they shut the entire region down
right like the entire nation goes down
and so there's a lot of procedure
involved yeah we all know if they if all
i do is tell meghan markle's and then
everyone's gonna know
i have blabber mouth oh i've been
reading those british taboos i know
everything about megan yeah where does
meghan markle stand in all this what's
her deal she's part of the family she's
part of uh she's prince harry's uh wife
but then they denounced she's part of
the expose of the family yeah right yeah
they are kind of i saw this meme of uh
pierce morgan coming up with ideas on
how to blame it on meghan markle that's
so great
what were some of the ideas
no it's just like it's like the media
yeah the media
they don't hate everybody they hate her
so they take every little thing and they
make it how mega marco sucks in some way
that's interesting though if if if they
needed time to like
100 i don't think we would be finding
out at the same time that prince charles
would be fine like there's no way oh
yeah right like i think
that makes no sense we're important too
though yeah that's what they need to do
prince charles actually knew that that
princess diana died before she died
which is kind of which is pretty good
too
it works on both sides
i mean i was in london in early in the
summer and they were thinking that do
you remember even back then they thought
she had already died
and so
i mean maybe she's been gone a lot
longer because people haven't seen her
in a very long time but she did just
take a picture with the new pm yeah
audition that was like last week or some
[ __ ] you guys do you guys think this is
very kim jones and she was she was in a
rose uh
she was driving a raindrop remember that
one
it was pretty [ __ ] funny yeah oh yeah
video of her going around driving yeah
so do you guys think
it really happened at 9 10
and then they announced it yeah yeah
they had to keep a lid on for a little
while
dude it's not bad they need to do that
for like philly before the eagles win
the super bowl again it's just like
barricade everything and they go all
right eagles won
[ __ ] everything up no [ __ ] though they
really do they need to like get their
telephone poles like really drilled into
that into that ground
do you guys see that [ __ ] well they
philly fans are [ __ ] nuts bro they
were they were hey they were climbing
telephone poles like [ __ ] swinging
from them and [ __ ] and throwing
batteries from his stuff what batteries
that's so funny
to imagine a city running that procedure
right we're gonna deepen every pole by
eight feet you have to what are you guys
doing
move along it's like hmm something seems
to be going on near the stadium the
eagle's gonna win
these holes are getting pretty deep
yeah i tried to buy batteries today
they're all gone
couldn't buy any batteries at all
[Music]
you